bryson is calling hey bryson welcome to
the show how can dr john and i help
hey dave it's true honor to speak with
you thank you you too man
hey so i am i just resigned from a
position
that i'm a teacher and i resigned for my
position back in june
and they're trying to say that i broke
contract and that i'm gonna owe them
five thousand dollars and they're gonna
take me to small claims court
i'm in baby step two right now and i was
wondering if i should be
saving money for you know i do
end up having to pay out money or if i
should just
continue paying off debt because there
is a possibility i might not have to pay
okay what was the five thousand dollars
for
well they are trying to say that that is
a fee
that i owe them because they are going
to incur costs needing to hire
and train new staff to replace me did
you did you violate your contract
so i did not violate any laws with the
iowa board of educational examiners
yeah that's not true yet yeah that's not
what i'm asking that
not that you you broke any laws or
anything but most
k-12 teachers sign sign annual contracts
to
for precisely this reason to keep
somebody from
quitting in the middle of the summer yes
i did sign a contract to return
back in march and then i did actually
reach out for legal counsel
and they told me that i should be able
to resign as long as i do it before june
30th
but of course i am great why did they
tell you that if you had a contract why
did they tell you you could break it
because they said that i was not
breaking any lies with the board of
educational examiners
who is your lawyer um i go to a private
association
here in iowa oh you didn't talk to a
real lawyer you talked to an idiot
okay because let me help you with this
okay the law
is one set of things john's pointing
that out and because you didn't violate
any laws doesn't mean you didn't break a
contract for instance you signed a
contract to buy a house
not not closing on the house and keeping
your promise on that contract
you're liable for getting sued for that
but you didn't break any laws
you don't go to jail you didn't break
any real estate laws you're not done
anything criminal
you've not done anything according to
the real estate commission
or anything else it's not even it's not
criminal it's not even a civil law that
you broke it's just you violated you
didn't keep your word
legally and there are costs with that so
that's what we're trying to ascertain
so yeah you need to talk to like a real
attorney and yes you need to stop your
baby step two because i think you're
probably gonna be writing a check
okay you're gonna lose that's my
prediction
okay because you got bad advice now that
i'm not a lawyer
i'm just a guy who's signed about eight
bazillion contracts in the last 40 years
in business
and uh they're real and i've helped
people to them
i've been held to them and uh
you know when it wasn't convenient and
and so forth and so and you know this
there's a spirit of the contract and
is there a uh is there a covid you know
a forced major clause
uh because of covid that you could get
out i don't know you need legal advice
and yes you need to stop your baby step
two and pile up some cash because you're
either going to
spend some money on a lawyer and or give
them five thousand dollars
i've been around city boards and
municipal boards and state boards of
education my whole career and
i've never heard of the financial clause
but i have heard them where they'll go
they'll take your license from you
your teaching license they'll suspend
you so they're serious about that
for again for precisely this reason
because it costs some money they want to
plan for the fall right yeah and now
they got to go run and replace the fall
right
so you probably with an attorney if
there's a force major
which is meaning in the in case of war
or national calamity
uh earthquakes hurricanes covids
and so on a lot of contracts are being
broke our people are walking out of a
lot of contracts right now on force
major
and uh uh because you know i've had some
with these live events where
the uh we were not able to hold the live
event
because of the municipality changed the
rules
and they said you can't do it and yet
i've got a contract with xyz
arena saying you'll show up so but under
the
you know force measure you know you i'm
walking out
you know and i and i'm out clean and so
there's a lot of people learning french
these days without letting me know i
mean i
honestly i've signed contracts with that
phrase in there my whole life i never
thought in my life
i would see a thing where i actually
activated something because of
something similar to an act of war wow
you know it's like
but but uh it it dates back to
well it dates way back but i mean the
last time you saw stuff like that really
activated was world war ii things shut
down
right i mean they repurposed factories
and started making tanks instead of
making refrigerators right
and so uh you know all of a sudden those
com you know there's
contracts that people were held to or
not held to and so
it became standard operating procedure
in business to have that so anyway you
need an attorney dude
i'm not one um but i think that
it sounds like you got bad advice to me
right uh on the surface and i'm afraid
you're going to lose that so you need
you you do need to stop your baby step
two
and um get ready and and
yeah um and if it may be that
man if something came up like you say
something happened i've
again been around educators that are
good people they want what's best they
got into that business because they like
helping people
and maybe you can go sit down and have a
conversation and they'll work with you
but well i think you might settle it it
doesn't feel good yeah
i thought you know maybe you pay a
thousand dollars to an attorney and you
settle it for two thousand dollars or
something but
because those costs are a little bit
nebulous right how you actually going to
prove exactly what it costs you to
replace a teacher
right um but the meta on that is if you
have an expense coming up down the road
that's probably gonna happen or maybe
gonna happen you're playing for it's
coming right
yeah and if you can't absorb it in your
budget which this is beyond that then
yeah you've got
you know there's a hurricane coming
right so you better get the plywood
right
for the windows that's what we're saying
and yeah that's a time you push pause
on your baby steps and you get ready for
the hurricane same thing is you know
a good a good version of that is a
baby's on the way
okay you know it's a good version right
and it's not a negative
situation in other words but we say stop
everything
get ready and um do that
not not directed at bryson because i
don't know the
we didn't get into the whole situation
but i think it's fair to comment in the
middle of this that
um when i got the real estate business
in 1978 when people wrote a contract to
buy a house you know what they did
they bought the house nowadays
they just kind of think it's like an
option it's just a holding period i'll
just lose my earnest money's on i'm not
gonna do it i changed my mind
i'm just gonna lose my earnest money and
there's a specific performance clause in
a real estate contract you can get your
butt sued absolutely and you can lose
and support force you to close on a
house you said you were gonna you ought
to not enter in and shake hands in a
pledge
and enter into a contract now again this
is not directed at bryson because i
don't know what all up he was up against
that we didn't get into that but
just in general one of the attributes of
people who
are successful in area every area of
their lives
is extreme fanatical levels of integrity
i tell folks i gave my son my face and
my last name
that's all i gave him right and i've
gotta defend both of those
and my face isn't pretty i gotta i gotta
lock down
on the integrity of my name well you are
in radio so there you go
this is the dave ramsey show